this is just too perfect
donald trump's beleaguered impeachment
lawyers
have misspelled united states
in one of the early documents they put
together
for the impeachment defense of donald
trump
instead of saying the united states
they wrote the unites states uni
t-e-s unites unites
states these were the lawyers
this is so insane these were the lawyers
hired
monday i guess after trump's original
lawyers quit on sunday night
um they uh this was a document
a 14-page legal brief um
written to members of the united states
senate
except instead it was written to members
of the united
states senate um it also
i mean listen it's remember when uh
i i can't believe this is the timeline
we're in but remember when rudy giuliani
um uh farted i mean i don't know what i
could use a more
you know i could use another term but
when rudy giuliani farted three or four
times during one of those bogus voter
fraud hearings
and of course the fart was covered
extensively but
it was not just the style that was weird
about that event with rudy giuliani
regularly farting while speaking
it was also the substance the substance
of what rudy said as i previously
reported to you was just as disgusting
and in this case it's not just that the
14-page legal brief
refers to the united states as the
united states
it's also that it makes absurd legal
arguments the 14-page
document argues that impeaching a former
president is unconstitutional now what
you have to
there's there's so many reasons this is
ridiculous first of all
senators don't decide about the
constitutionality
of things in the united states this is a
political
trial okay and although
arguably too many senators are former
lawyers and i've
are i've advocated for more uh diversity
in the types of folks
uh who are u.s senators and and members
of congress
it is not up to the senate to determine
the constitutionality of things that's
number one so
a defense of trump based on the alleged
unconstitutionality
of an after the presidency impeachment
is unfortunately invalid at its base but
it doesn't matter because they can make
whatever argument they want and the
senate can can
accept or reject the argument but more
importantly trump was not
impeached once he was no longer in
office and even more importantly
you can impeach a president after they
are out of office remember
the trial is happening after trump is
out of office
but impeachment happens in the house of
representatives and impeachment took
place
before january 20th when the house of
representatives impeached donald trump
for a second time
donald trump was president of the united
states uh unless
time now functions in a in some other
way that i don't uh understand
but the senate has previously had trials
on impeachment for officials who at that
point had already
left office so what's more embarrassing
in the end
that trump's own lawyers couldn't even
correctly spell
the name of the country in which these
proceedings are taking place
or the fact that they're making an
argument that is not only wrong but also
pathetic
and not up to the jurisdiction of the
senate take your pick
it's like uh it's like a choose your own
adventure
and um according to a report from axios
uh
trump has actually started to sort of
privately concede that a lot of the
representation he's had has been
embarrassing to him
it reflects a certain amount of
self-awareness that we've not really
seen from donald trump during his
presidency but at this point who even
cares this is starting
on tuesday we'll be covering much of it
and if this is a sign
if united states is any indication of
how
trump's legal team is going to perform
at next week's impeachment trial
it's going to be quite a quite a scene
to watch and we'll be covering much of
it
when i read united states it reminded me
of god bless
the united sheish many of you i'm sure
remember that the israelis
and palestinians how does this even
happen like
doesn't spell check protect this uh
prevent this from happening like i'm
talking on a technical level how does it
actually happen
and um what one other thought i had as i
was reading this is
one of the big supposed selling points
about donald trump when he was running
for president
was that his best skill is hiring people
only the best people he's the he might
not know about
foreign policy he might not be an expert
on
uh you know what whatever anything uh
but he hires the best people
and i have a hard time thinking of
someone who has demonstrated themselves
to be
worse at hiring people than donald trump
has been trump's best
hilariously or sadly trump's best
employee
might have been christopher krebs who
said the election was secure
and you really lost mr president and
trump fired that guy
the few people that by mere chance seem
to be reasonable people that trump has
hired or allowed to work for him
seem to be the first ones that donald
trump fires and
it is all a comedy of errors uh and we
will be covering it we will be covering
much of next week's impeachment trial
live on
youtube twitch and facebook and i hope
that you will join me
we will also have continued coverage of
the united
states on our instagram page you can
find us
at davidpakmanshow on instagram and
follow me while you're there
at david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and be back
with tom hartman right after this when
you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing
a shirt by a company called teddy
stratford and i love these shirts so
much that i
asked teddy stratford to be a sponsor of
the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really
improve the way your upper body looks
when you're wearing it it also has a
special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down and
spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things
really do a lot to make a big difference
when you're looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout